We had a course in second year where we learned Ada and we wrote this, we had this big, huge class project. And that was the only Ada, but there was no compiler at the time. It was too early. Wait, but when you say there's no compiler, do you mean you just didn't run the code? No, you couldn't. The compiler that we had access to in New York University did not actually produce machine code. It just said this. It was like the first stage of a compiler.
我们大二时有一门课，学习了 Ada，然后我们写了这个……我们有一个非常庞大的课堂项目。那是唯一一次用 Ada，但当时还没有编译器。太早了。等等，但当你说没有编译器时，你是说你只是不运行代码吗？不，你没法运行。我们在纽约大学可以访问的编译器实际上并不生成机器码。它只是显示这个。它就像编译器的第一阶段。
It had no backend. It had no code generation. Wow. So you only knew that your code was syntactically and I guess semantically correct. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 154 recorded on October 18th, 2023. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue part three of our four-part conversation with Jonathan O'Connor. On today's episode, we continue our comparison of Pascal versus C versus Ada, and go on to talk about a plethora of other programming languages. Zig, Nim, Carbon, Eiffel, WeWa, Clojure are all languages that get mentioned in this episode.
它没有后端。它没有代码生成。哇。所以你只知道你的代码在语法上、我猜还有语义上是正确的。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 154 期，录制于 2023 年 10 月 18 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，继续我们与乔纳森·奥康纳（Jonathan O'Connor）四部分对话的第三部分。在今天的节目中，我们将继续对比 Pascal、C 和 Ada，并讨论大量其他编程语言。Zig、Nim、Carbon、Eiffel、WeWa、Clojure 都是本期节目中提到的语言。
So I don't know that we bottomed out on talking about Ada. Oh yeah, no, wait. So, I mean, we're hopping all over the place. I was, while you were explaining the power of visualization in paper, because at one point we had, so we're even rewinding more back from Ada. We'll get back to Ada in a sec. I was trying to figure out what the internet has to say of why C won out over Pascal. And so the summary, first of all, Pascal is actually older than C. I did not know that. C, according to Wikipedia's first year of appearance was 1972, and Pascal's was 1970. And the general opinion of the internet, there are many different hot takes, but the most popular one is that Pascal was designed to be a language for teaching
所以我不知道我们是否彻底探讨完了 Ada。哦，对，等等。所以，我的意思是，我们思绪乱飞。当你在解释纸上可视化的威力时，因为在某个时候我们有——所以我们甚至从 Ada 倒退了更多。我们一会儿会回到 Ada。我当时在试图弄清楚互联网是怎么看待 C 语言为什么能战胜 Pascal 的。所以总结一下，首先，Pascal 实际上比 C 更古老。我当时并不知道这一点。根据维基百科，C 语言首次出现于 1972 年，而 Pascal 是 1970 年。互联网的普遍看法有很多不同的热门观点，但最流行的一种是，Pascal 被设计成一门用于教学的语言，
and C was designed to be a language for doing systems programming and getting things done. And what that meant is that as a teaching language, C isn't great because you got many foot guns, you can make many mistakes as a beginner, but that's the kind of power you want when you're trying to write a system. Whereas Pascal did not have those foot guns, you can you can make many mistakes as a beginner. But that's the kind of power you want when you're trying to write a system. Whereas Pascal did not have those foot guns, but it kind of made things more difficult. I mean, one of the the top things that came across answers was that Pascal, I'm not sure if this changed with all future versions of Pascal,
而 C 语言被设计成一门用于进行系统编程和完成任务的语言。这意味着作为一门教学语言，C 语言并不是很好，因为你有很多“自我伤害”的陷阱，作为初学者你会犯很多错误，但这就是你试图编写系统时所需要的那种强大功能。而 Pascal 没有那些陷阱，作为初学者你可能会犯很多错误。但这就是你试图编写系统时所需要的那种强大功能。而 Pascal 没有那些陷阱，但它让事情变得更困难了。我的意思是，最主要的答案之一是，Pascal——我不确定 Pascal 的所有未来版本是否都改变了这一点，
but at one point, all of your code had to be in a single source file, which does sound pretty crazy. I'm not sure if you recall, Jonathan, if that was the case when you were using Pascal. That might have been the case, but I would have thought you could just type, you just say, you know, Pascal or whatever, PC or whatever the thing was, and the list of files, I guess, to compile all of them into one group.
但在某一点上，你所有的代码都必须在一个单一的源文件中，这听起来确实挺疯狂的。乔纳森，我不确定你是否还记得，当你使用 Pascal 时是不是这样。情况可能确实如此，但我会以为你只要打字，只要说，你知道，Pascal 什么的，PC 或者无论那是什么东西，然后列出文件，我想，把它们全部编译成一个组。
But maybe that's true, because I think that was the big thing with ada um because ada uh started they had this notion of packages that was one of their big selling points it was for large application development um with large teams and you could you could have a package specification and a package body. So you had the split between declaration and implementation. And that was huge.
但也许这是真的，因为我认为这就是 Ada 的大事件，因为 Ada 开始时他们有包（packages）的概念，那是他们的卖点之一，它是为了大型应用程序开发而设计的，适用于大型团队，你可以拥有包规范和包主体。所以你有声明和实现的分离。这太巨大了。
I mean, that's what we spent most of our time doing was just writing package specifications rather than implementations in that project that we did. But yeah, you had the huge thing about packages and packages could have, they were like namespaces. They're similar to namespaces in in c++ except you can also uh i guess no they're not my classes but you could you had functions procedures um and you could have data inside them so you can have what's the difference between a function and a procedure in? A function has all input parameters
我的意思是，我们在那个项目中花了大半时间做的，只是编写包规范，而不是实现。但是，是的，关于包，这是一件大事，包可以有，它们就像命名空间。它们类似于 C++ 中的命名空间，除了你还可以——我想不，它们不是类，但你可以有函数、过程，并且你可以在它们内部拥有数据，所以你可以有——函数和过程有什么区别？函数拥有所有的输入参数，
and it returns a value. And procedures can have input and output. And I don't think they have any, no, they don't have any return value. But yeah, you could, I mean, from what I remember, Ada didn't have object orientation built into it. You had a package.
并且它返回一个值。而过程可以有输入和输出。而且我认为它们没有任何——不，它们没有任何返回值。但是，是的，从我记的情况来看，Ada 没有内置面向对象。你有一个包。
You could create a global variable inside the package that was private to the package, and you could refer to things in that. You could hand out these, what was called limited something or there um where you you'd have they were just like handles um to something and and people outside the package couldn't do anything with them except pass them around um and that way you could you could you could set up stacks and whatever but um you know there was no kind of you could there was no such thing as a class um which was interesting i also just looked up so ada was created in 1980 so that's a decade roughly a decade after both uh pascal and c
你可以在包内部创建一个全局变量，它是该包私有的，你可以引用该包中的事物。你可以分发这些被称为“受限某某”之类的东西，在那里你会有——它们就像是指针句柄——指向某个东西，包外的人除了传递它们之外什么也做不了，通过这种方式，你可以设置栈以及诸如此类的东西，但是，你知道，没有那种——没有类这种东西，这很有趣。我还顺便查了一下，Ada 创建于 1980 年，所以这大约是 Pascal 和 C 双方诞生十年之后的事了。
and it says right in the first line on the Wikipedia page that it was primarily inspired by Pascal but that uh it was I didn't actually know this it was it was a created by a guy at Honeywell whose name I'm gonna mess up yeah what's his name Jean Jean Icbia yeah I think so probably that's something else but but that's how i pronounce it as well and it was uh i guess so french computer scientist honeywell famously an american company though and they were contracted by the us dod department of defense to create this language ada specifically to replace a whole bunch of languages that the DoD was using at the time. And it also has this little byline, in strong typing we trust. So it's clearly this,
维基百科页面的第一行就指出，它主要受 Pascal 启发，但它——我实际上并不知道这一点——它是由霍尼韦尔（Honeywell）的一个人创建的，他的名字我可能会拼错，对，他叫什么名字？让·伊奇比亚（Jean Ichbiah），对，我想可能是吧，也许是别的什么，但这也是我的发音方式。而且它是一个——我猜是一个法国计算机科学家，不过霍尼韦尔出名地是一家美国公司，他们被美国国防部（US DoD）合同委任来创建这门语言 Ada，专门用于取代国防部当时正在使用的一大堆语言。它还有这样一句标语：“我们信赖强类型”。所以这显然是一门，
you know, government funded for government purposes language. That's one of the things that Ada has that C++ still doesn't. It had strong typedefs. So you could create my, you could say using my int equals int, say, and that would be, you can't do arithmetic between ints and myints. They're totally separate and they don't go together. So that's something that we don't have in C++ still. Interesting. So it's a type alias that does not interrupt with the underlying type. Correct. Correct. Interesting.
你知道的，由政府资助、用于政府目的的语言。这是 Ada 拥有而 C++ 至今仍然没有的东西之一。它拥有强类型别名（typedefs）。所以你可以创建我的——你可以说 `using my_int = int` 之类的，那将是——你不能在 `int` 和 `my_int` 之间进行算术运算。它们是完全独立的，不能混在一起。所以这是我们 C++ 中至今仍然没有的东西。有趣。所以它是一个不与底层类型交互的类型别名。没错。没错。有趣。
And then I assume that Ada has some facility for casting or static casting. There probably was, but you'd probably, yeah, there must have been some way of casting to the underlying low-level integer. And the other thing you could do, you just had integer and you had float. But you could specify that your integer had to have a range from like 0 to 1 billion or something like that. And the compiler would figure out how many bytes to use for its integer type. And so that actually, so that was one of the things
然后我假设 Ada 有某种用于强制转换或静态转换的机制。可能存在，但你可能——是的，肯定有某种方法可以转换为底层的低级整数。你能做的另一件事是，你只有整数（integer）和浮点数（float）。但你可以指定你的整数必须有一个范围，比如从 0 到 10 亿左右。然后编译器会弄清楚为其整数类型使用多少字节。所以这实际上，所以这是关于 Ada 的事情之一，
that I did know about Ada is that it has bounded and fixed point. So it has a richer type system for your integer types that you might want. And I was perusing through ADSP, the Virth book, looking at a couple of examples. And it looks like they actually had the same similar syntax for that kind of stuff. Oh, maybe, maybe, yeah.
我知道它有有界类型和定点类型。因此，对于你可能想要的整数类型，它有一个更丰富的类型系统。我正在浏览 ADSP，维尔特（Wirth）的那本书，看几个例子。看起来他们实际上也有类似语法的这类东西。哦，也许，也许，是的。
It had this type keyword, and it said type digit, and then 0.9. So my guess is that is defining an integer type. I could be wrong about that, but combining this with the fact that Ada was, you know, inspired by Pascal, I wouldn't be surprised if Pascal is another example of a language that has, I'm not sure about the fixed point type, but the bounded integer types. And speaking of Pascal, again, that was the other thing the internet said, is that C is not really known to have killed Pascal. It was actually Java, Because what Pascal was good at, and it was what the domain that it was successful in, was being taught in universities. It was a teaching language. And so that's where it kind of thrived. And then when Java came out in the 1990s, and there was a
它有这个 `type` 关键字，上面写着 `type digit`，然后是 `0..9`。所以我的猜测是那是在定义一个整数类型。我可能猜错了，但结合 Ada 是受 Pascal 启发这一事实，如果 Pascal 是另一个拥有这种特性的语言的例子，我也不会感到惊讶，我不确定定点类型，但有界整数类型是有的。说到 Pascal，这又是互联网所说的另一件事，那就是 C 语言其实并不是公认的杀死 Pascal 的凶手。实际上是 Java，因为 Pascal 擅长的领域，也是它取得成功的领域，是在大学里被教授。它是一门教学语言。所以这就是它蓬勃发展的地方。然后当 Java 在 20世纪90年代问世时，并且有了一次
huge marketing blitz, a ton of universities switched from whatever language they were using, you know, insert a language, and a lot of those might have been Pascal. And then Java became the one of the de facto teaching languages up until when I was in university, you know, in 2008, the first, I think it was the second course, the first course taught Python and the second course taught Java. So interesting that, you know, C and Pascal, even though they were quote unquote contemporaries, it's at least the internet doesn't think that it was it wasn't the success of c that like killed pascal it was more that it was a great teaching language but then uh that was surpassed by something else but i think i think i maybe see
巨大的营销攻势，大量的大学从他们正在使用的任何语言（插入一门语言），其中许多可能都是 Pascal，转向了 Java。然后 Java 成了事实上的教学语言之一，一直持续到我上大学的时候，你知道，在 2008 年，第一门——我想是第二门课，第一门课教 Python，第二门课教 Java。所以很有趣，你知道，C 和 Pascal，尽管它们是所谓的“同时代产品”，但至少互联网不认为——杀死 Pascal 的不是 C 的成功，而是它曾是一门极好的教学语言，但随后被其他东西超越了。但我想，我想也许 C 也是因为
also because it was used as the the system language for for all these unix systems. And those Unix systems started getting very popular and it became a language that you'd write code on PCs. So I think, yeah, just you could, as you said, you could get things done with C. And then you had Microsoft producing compiler. Do they also have a Pascal compiler? I mean, Turbo Pascal was the big thing in the late 80s, early 90s. And that had a nice IDE.
它被用作所有这些 Unix 系统的系统语言。而这些 Unix 系统开始变得非常流行，它成为了一种你在个人电脑（PC）上编写代码的语言。所以我想，是的，正如你所说，你可以用 C 完成事情。然后你有了微软生产编译器。他们也有 Pascal 编译器吗？我的意思是，Turbo Pascal 是 80 年代末、90 年代初的大热门。而且它有一个很好的 IDE。
It was very, very fast to compile and build. So that was kind of really nice to use. Yeah. I mean, that was definitely something that came up in the answers was that the fact that Unix was written in C and it shipped with, I think, the C compiler, not only did that have a huge impact on educational institutions that were getting Unix computers,
它编译和构建的速度非常非常快。所以用起来真的很不错。是的。我的意思是，答案中肯定出现过的一点是，Unix 是用 C 编写的并且自带了——我认为是 C 编译器，这不仅对获得 Unix 计算机的教育机构产生了巨大影响，
but also a ton of folks that were at Bell or other places that had experience with Unix when they went to go do their own companies. It was a very easy choice to build their whatever, you know, hardware or software they were building on top of Unix, which, you know, C becomes a very good option because it's there. And it's if you're doing stuff that interops with the OS, yeah, interesting. So that brings us back to Ada. So Ada is this government-funded, you know, language designed for the government. Military Standard 1858 is the official, the original thing.
而且还有大量在贝尔实验室或其他地方有 Unix 经验的人，当他们去开办自己的公司时。在 Unix 之上构建他们的任何硬件或软件，这是一个非常容易的选择，你知道，C 变成了一个非常好的选择，因为它就在那里。而且如果你做的事情与操作系统互操作，是的，有趣。所以这把我们带回了 Ada。所以 Ada 是一门政府资助的、你知道的为政府设计的语言。军用标准 1858（Military Standard 1858）是官方的、最初的东西。
M-I-L-S-T-D 1858. It was a military standard for for the department of defense in america and they chose 1858 which because i think that was ada lovelace's date of birth or date of death um interesting so it's just a random four digit number it's not it's not like it's not a random four digit number no no it isn't um or be like it's it's just a random four digit number it's not it's not like it's not a random four digit number no no it isn't um or but like it's it's not a number that it was the next number in like a sequence of you know paper numbers like for the iso i don't believe it i don't believe it no don't believe it was interesting um and so did you do any ada programming when you were in school
M-I-L-S-T-D 1858。它是美国国防部的一个军用标准，他们选择了 1858，因为我认为那是阿达·洛芙莱斯（Ada Lovelace）的出生日期或逝世日期，有趣。所以它只是一个随机的四位数，它不是——它不是像一个随机的四位数，不，它不是——或者说它——它只是一个随机的四位数，它不是——它不是像一个随机的四位数，不，它不是——或者说，它不是像国际标准化组织（ISO）纸质编号那样序列中的下一个数字，我不相信，我不相信。这很有趣。那么你在学校做过任何 Ada 编程吗？
or yeah for for we had a course in second year where we we learned ada and we wrote this we we had this big huge class project and that was the only ada but there was no compiler at the time it was too early that they there was this wait but when you say there's no compiler do you mean you just didn't run the code no you couldn't the compiler that we had access to in new york university did not actually produce uh machine code it just said this it was like the first stage of a compiler it had no back end there's no code generation uh wow so you could own you only knew that your code was syntactically and I guess semantically correct. So what causes a professor or a university to teach a course in a language that doesn't have a full end-to-end working compiler?
或者——是的，我们在大二时有一门课，我们学习了 Ada，我们写了——我们有一个非常庞大的课堂项目，那是唯一一次用 Ada，但当时还没有编译器，太早了，以至于他们有这个——等等，但当你说没有编译器时，你是说你只是不运行代码吗？不，你没法运行。我们在纽约大学可以访问的编译器实际上并没有产生机器码，它只是说这个……它就像编译器的第一阶段。它没有后端，没有代码生成。哇。所以你只能——你只知道你的代码在语法上、我猜还有语义上是正确的。那么，是什么导致一个教授或一门大学课程去教一门没有完整的端到端工作编译器的语言呢？
I think it's probably an experiment. I suspect it was an experiment. That is like, I'm not sure. Is that the equivalent of like a university? I mean, I guess it was government funded. So they knew that at some point there was going to be Ada jobs. But I mean, it sounds like a university choosing Carbon as like, we're going to teach and Carbon has an interpreter.
我想这可能是一个实验。我怀疑这是一个实验。这就像是，我不确定。这是否相当于某种大学级别的——我的意思是，我猜它是政府资助的。所以他们知道在某些时候会有 Ada 的工作岗位。但这听起来就像一所大学选择 Carbon，就像是：我们要教 Carbon，而且 Carbon 有一个解释器。
You can, you know, write some code in it. people who did computer science in the 1970s. You'll find a huge number of them have got their PhD by creating a language to investigate some aspect of computer science. And so there were hundreds, if not, yeah, definitely maybe even thousands of languages created in the 70s. And that kept on for another few years. And then people stopped creating languages, I think. And, you know, from the 90s, I think, didn't have that many languages created. There were a few big ones. And now we seem to, after maybe like 10, 15 years
你可以在其中编写一些代码。在 20世纪70年代学习计算机科学的人。你会发现其中有相当大一部分人是通过创建一门语言来研究计算机科学的某个方面从而获得了博士学位。所以在 70 年代创建的语言有数百种，如果不是——是的，绝对甚至可能是数千种。这种情况又持续了几几年。然后人们停止了创建语言，我想。而且，你知道，从 90 年代开始，我想，没有创建那么多的语言。有几个大的。而现在我们似乎在经历了大概 10、15 年
of no new languages, now suddenly we're getting a whole load of new languages like Zig and Nim, as well as the C++ once carbonate. Wewa? Wewa? And Wewa, yes. The funnest language to say. I wonder if there's a graph. I wonder what causes these. I mean, clearly in the 70s software
没有新语言之后，现在突然涌现出了一大堆新语言，比如 Zig 和 Nim，还有 C++ 阵营的 Carbon。Wewa？Wewa？还有 Wewa，是的。最有趣的发音语言。我想知道是否存在一张图表。我想知道是什么导致了这些。我的意思是，显然在 70 年代，软件工程、计算机科学是一个萌芽中的、你知道的——你称之为什么？新兴领域，并且有很多研究课题，
engineering computer science it's it's a a burgeoning you know uh what do you call it emerging field and there's a ton of research topics um but then what caused you know the 90s to to be what did they call it a nad nadir, a trough, if you will. Probably people started trying to make money out of, you know, by writing applications that actual people wanted to use. So it went from, you know, the laboratory or from academia to the real world. Oh, I'm going to insult somebody there. That's all right we're we love maybe i'll maybe i'll insert the uh was it the the hot take or spicy take uh yeah k-pop song but but yeah i think i think that's what happened and you had and so we had i mean there was turbo pascal there was there was c plus plus was getting big. There was Eiffel briefly.
但后来是什么导致了 90 年代变成——他们称之为低谷（nadir），如果你愿意的话，是一个低谷。可能人们开始试图通过编写真实人们想要使用的应用程序来赚钱。所以它从实验室或学术界走向了现实世界。哦，我要在那里冒犯某个人了。没关系，我们喜欢——也许我会插入那个——是那个热门观点或辛辣观点吗？——是的，K-pop 歌曲。但，是的，我想——我想这就是发生的事情，你有了——所以我们有了——我的意思是，有 Turbo Pascal，有 C++ 变得很大。曾短暂出现过 Eiffel。
I remember going to a conference in Germany, a one-day conference in Germany with – who was the guy who headed Eiffel, who created Eiffel? A French guy. Very clever man. I feel like I would know the name. I know it was the language of contracts. Yes. And it had a terrific book. He had a terrific book.
我记得去德国参加过一个会议，在德国的一个为期一天的会议，跟——那个领导 Eiffel、创建 Eiffel 的人是谁？一个法国人。非常聪明的人。我觉得我应该知道这个名字。我知道那是契约语言。是的。而且它有一本极棒的书。他有一本极棒的书。
It was... Oh, yes. Bertrand Meyer. And poor old Bertrand, he absolutely, he found it so hard to have to accept that C++ was the more popular language. He found that very hard to take because he just saw all the inadequacies of C++ where his language Eiffel was beautiful. And it is a beautiful language. And he had a lovely standard library. He had all sorts of very clever ideas on data structures
那是……哦，是的，伯特兰·迈耶（Bertrand Meyer）。可怜的老伯特兰，他绝对——他发现接受 C++ 成为更受欢迎的语言是如此困难。他发现这很难接受，因为他只看到了 C++ 的所有不足，而他的语言 Eiffel 是美丽的。它确实是一门美丽的语言。他有一个可爱的标准库。他关于数据结构以及它们的共同点有哪些，有着各种非常聪明的想法。我当时想，是的，我觉得它太棒了。但是，是的，Eiffel 是另一门似乎来去匆匆的语言。
and how they were, what was common about them. And I thought, yeah, I thought it was excellent. But yeah, E ifl was another language that seems to have come and gone um yeah what is bjorn is uh i mean whether you disagree or agree with uh his takes over time he has that one quote is there's uh two types of languages languages that people complain about and languages that people don't use which i mean is uh it's a good one there's definitely some truth in that uh yeah i mean there's there's so many like ada i know has got much bigger i mean the i'm yeah this is the ada reference manual you can only it's it's like a centimeter thick
是的，比雅尼（Bjarne）是——我的意思是，无论你是否不同意或同意他随时间推移的观点，他都有那句名言：有两种类型的语言，人们抱怨的语言和人们不用的语言。我的意思是，这是一句好话。这绝对有几分道理。是的，我的意思是，有太多了——比如 Ada，我知道它变得大得多，我的意思是——是的，这是 Ada 参考手册，你只能——它就像一厘米厚，
this part that the second half of this book. So it's only about 120 pages long or so. And I noticed there I downloaded the C Sharp standard. There was a link that was sent out that I get. And I looked at it, it was 400 pages long. And of course, C++ is 2,000 pages long, the standard. Yeah, hold my beer. So I think, yeah, the languages were much smaller then and they are not anymore.
这本书的后半部分。所以它只有大约 120 页左右。我注意到那里我下载了 C# 标准。有一个链接被发送出来，我收到了。我看了看，它有 400 页厚。当然，C++ 的标准有 2000 页厚。是的，拭目以待吧。所以我想，是的，那时的语言要小得多，而现在不再是了。
I think it's so, I mean, I love thinking about it. I've watched a couple different talks, Richard Feldman, a fellow podcaster now of software unscripted. He has a really popular talk called why isn't functional programming the norm. And that talk talks about like, what, what is it that actually makes a language popular as successful? And just recently I watched a talk from Jamesames gosling famously the creator of java and he was talking at a online conference in 2022 called reclosure so it was a closure event and
我觉得这太——我的意思是，我喜欢思考这个问题。我看过几个不同的演讲，理查德·费尔德曼（Richard Feldman），现在也是《软件无脚本》（Software Unscripted）的同行播客。他有一个非常受欢迎的演讲，叫《为什么函数式编程不是常态》（Why isn't functional programming the norm）。那个演讲讨论了——到底是什么让一门语言变得流行或成功？就在最近，我看了詹姆斯·高斯林（James Gosling）的一个演讲，他是 Java 的著名创造者，他在 2022 年一个名为 ReClojure 的在线会议上发言，所以这是一个 Clojure 活动，
for those of you that don't know closure is a a lisp that runs on the jvm so it's kind of in the java family of languages similar to Scala and Kotlin. And he was talking about at one point in the talk, you know, what is it that the same thing? What is it that makes a language successful? And you know, how much of it is familiarity and trying to meet developers, you know, where they're at, because there's a lot of great novel ideas that exist in these kind of unique languages. But if it's, different or feels too foreign, people are repelled from it. You know, I think APL is a, you know, although APL had its heyday in the 60s and 70s. But, you know, these days you make videos and people just are kind of shocked by it.
对于那些不知道 Clojure 是什么的人来说，它是一个运行在 JVM 上的 Lisp，所以它有点像 Java 家族的语言，类似于 Scala 和 Kotlin。他在演讲中的某个时刻谈到了，你知道，到底是什么——同样的事情？到底是什么让一门语言成功？你知道，其中有多少是熟悉度，并试图在开发者所在的地方迎合他们，因为这些独特的语言中存在许多伟大的新颖想法。但如果它是不同的或者感觉太陌生，人们就会排斥它。你知道，我认为 APL 是一个——尽管 APL 在 60 年代和 70 年代有过它的全盛时期。但是，你知道，如今你制作视频，人们只会对此感到震惊。
But I think there's like a more nuanced question to be asked is like, I think the things that made languages popular in the 70s and 80s is now different than what makes a language popular today. Because back in the 70s and 80s, you had less history and existing code to compete with. And now, in order for like a language to compete in the C++ space, you know, you're competing with the whole infrastructure and ecosystem, as Bryce mentioned in the most recent episode. There's millions, if not billions of lines of code that represents like, you know, technology and effort and value that, you know, has to go get displaced if, you know, you, if that's your goal of your,
但我认为有一个更微妙的问题要问，那就是——我认为在 70 年代和 80 年代使语言流行的因素，现在已经不同于今天使语言流行的因素了。因为在 70 年代和 80 年代，你需要与之竞争的历史和现有代码更少。而现在，为了让一门语言在 C++ 领域竞争，你知道，你正在与整个基础设施和生态系统竞争，正如布莱斯在最近一期节目中所提到的。有数百万甚至数十亿行代码代表着——你知道的——技术、精力和价值，如果——你知道，如果那是你的目标的话，这些都必须被取代，
you know, whether it's Rust or whatever. And so the question is, you know, like, overall, what is it that makes a language successful? But then also too, like, what is it that makes a language successful today? Like, is it, you you know i don't have the answer to the question i mean jonathan you've you've been in the industry a lot longer than we have and you've worked with you know c++ lisp uh ada pascal ruby java like you have thoughts or you know i don't know what makes the language popular i do know that most of us want to use a single language rather than multiple languages. We want to have a single hammer
无论是 Rust 还是其他什么。所以问题是，你知道，总的来说，到底是什么让一门语言成功？但话又说回来，到底是什么让一门语言在今天成功？比如，是不是——你知道，我没有这个问题的答案。我的意思是，乔纳森，你在行业里的时间比我们长得多，你用过——你知道，C++、Lisp、Ada、Pascal、Ruby、Java——你有什么想法吗？或者——我不知道是什么让一门语言流行，但我确实知道我们大多数人更愿意使用单一语言而不是多种语言。我们希望拥有一把单一的锤子，
because we look at everything as a nail. And so you see things like, I don't understand why people want to use things like React in the JavaScript world, where you use JavaScript to generate HTML and CSS for web pages. There are three languages there, JavaScript for dynamism,
因为我们把每件事都看作钉子。所以你会看到这样的事情，我不明白为什么人们想在 JavaScript 世界里使用像 React 这样的东西，在那里你用 JavaScript 为网页生成 HTML 和 CSS。那里有三种语言，JavaScript 用于动态性，
HTML for static structure, and CSS for making it pretty yes and styling and they all those languages do their job very well but there are now javascript frameworks where you do everything in javascript and i i and that's an example. And in the C++ world, we prefer, we like, well, in any programming world, we like to say we want to use the same language. Look at, what's that?
HTML 用于静态结构，而 CSS 用于让它变漂亮——是的——以及样式。所有这些语言都很好地完成了它们的工作，但现在有些 JavaScript 框架让你完全用 JavaScript 做所有事情，我——而这就是一个例子。而在 C++ 世界里，我们更喜欢，我们喜欢——好吧，在任何编程世界里，我们都喜欢说我们想用同一门语言。看看，那个是什么？
Web-asm. Oh, yeah, WebAssembly. Yeah, you can write C++ code and it runs in your browser. And people tend, or Node.js, where both the server and the front end, the browser, are running JavaScript. That's another example of having a single tool.
Web-asm。哦，对，WebAssembly。是的，你可以编写 C++ 代码，它在你的浏览器中运行。人们倾向于，或者 Node.js，服务器和前端（浏览器）都在运行 JavaScript。那是拥有单一工具的另一个例子。
And maybe it's just that, you know, these languages have grown, they're quite big, it takes quite some time to understand them and learn them and therefore you want to use them everywhere because you don't want you don't have time or or it costs too much to train people in another language so well so here's a related question what made you uh when you switched languages was that just a what do you call it a byproduct of switching to a new role and it was like a it was a necessity for what you were doing or like because at what you went from c++ to java to ruby and you actually did explain why you went from java to ruby that was someone patted you on
也许只是因为，你知道，这些语言已经成长了，它们相当庞大，理解和学习它们需要相当长的时间，因此你希望到处使用它们，因为你不想——你没有时间或者培训人们使用另一门语言的成本太高。所以，这里有一个相关的问题：是什么促使你——当你切换语言时，那仅仅是——你称之为——切换到新角色的副产品，它是你正在做的事情的必需品，还是因为——因为你从 C++ 转向了 Java 再到 Ruby，你确实解释了为什么你从 Java 转向 Ruby，那是有人拍拍你的肩膀说，也许去看看这个叫 Ruby 的东西，可能会让你的生活更简单。但随后你又回到了 C++。那么，有没有，你知道，原因，你知道，你……
the shoulder and said maybe check out this thing thing called Ruby might make your life simpler. But then you went back to C++. Like, were there, you know, reasons, you know, that you. I think what Connor is really asking is what makes a rational man go from C++ to Java. Well, at the time, actually, actually there, Bryce,ce i can tell you i can tell you something like when i moved to java in 2001 java had reflection you could you could fair that's i mean i mean shots fired shots fired the 90s era C++ was pretty rough. Yeah. But, yeah, you can see in like Ruby was really popular from about 2005, maybe to when I stopped using it in 2016. But you could see that people who were the top people in Ruby,
我想康纳真正想问的是，是什么让一个理性的人从 C++ 转向 Java。好吧，当时，其实，其实——布莱斯，我可以告诉你——我可以告诉你一些事情，当我 2001 年转向 Java 时，Java 有反射（reflection），你可以——好吧，那是——我的意思是，开炮了，开炮了。90 年代初期的 C++ 相当艰难。是的。但是，是的，你可以看到，比如 Ruby 从 2005 年左右开始非常流行，直到我 2016 年停止使用它。但你可以看到，Ruby 领域顶尖的人，
they had decided that it got too popular and they wanted to move on to the next new fresh thing. And so a lot of them chose Elixir in the Ruby community. And I think Elixir, well, again, people say they don't want to have to maintain their old code. And so by changing languages, they don't have to. I mean, I've never heard that one before, but that is, I mean, that's a good, that is a solution to a problem that you don't want to solve. Yeah, you don't want to, you don't want to have to look at your old code. So you switch languages, and then you get to write new code. And maybe you're solving similar problems that you solved before in a different language. So you have a better idea of how to solve them. And the new language gives you other interesting capabilities. That reminds me of the K-language guy
他们已经决定它变得太流行了，他们想转向下一个全新的、新鲜的事物。所以他们当中很多人在 Ruby 社区中选择了 Elixir。我认为 Elixir，好吧，同样，人们说他们不想维护他们的旧代码。因此，通过更换语言，他们就不必这样做了。我的意思是，我以前从未听过那种说法，但那是——我的意思是，这是一个好主意，这是一个你不想解决的问题的解决方案。是的，你不想——你不想去看你的旧代码。所以你换了语言，然后你就可以写新代码了。也许你正在用一门不同的语言解决以前在旧语言中解决过的类似问题。所以你对如何解决它们有了更好的想法。而新语言为你提供了其他有趣的功能。这让我想起了 K 语言的那个人，
who would just every couple of years just write a new version and then just delete. It's a tragedy. As time goes on, the immensity of the tragedy of what he's doing like don't get me wrong one of the smartest people i've ever met in my life the guy is is clearly you know a genius and um you know there's some joke on the internet it's you know arthur whitney was blessed by the coding gods but you know his curse with the the abilities that he was given is that you know the languages
他每隔几年就会写一个新版本，然后就直接删除。这是一个悲剧。随着时间的推移，他所做的事情的悲剧的巨大性——别误会我，我一生中遇到过最聪明的人之一，这家伙显然——你知道的——是个天才，而且——你知道的，互联网上有个笑话，就是说阿瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney）受到了编码之神的祝福，但你知道，他被赋予的能力所带来的诅咒是，你知道，他创造的语言和他写的代码，你知道的，对大多数人来说是不可读的，我只是觉得他按下删除键太遗憾了，因为他实际上——我不认为他是故意的，但就像是在摧毁历史和社区。我的意思是，我已经说过好几次了，就像 K 程序员一样，如果你作为一个群体问他们，哪个版本——或者不是版本，因为它们是不同的语言，但如果我想去学 K，我该去学哪个？K4、K6、K7？你会得到不同的答案。每个版本都有不同的文档。这就相当于——想象一下，所有不同的 Lisp 都是由一个人创造的，你知道的，这个神一般的实体。每次——你知道的，这个人从 Lisp 转向 Common Lisp，转向 Scheme，
he created in the code he wrote was you know in unreadable by by most people and i just think it's such a shame that he hits the delete button because he effectively i don't think intentionally but like is destroying the history and the community i mean mean, I've said this a couple of times, like the K programmers, if you ask them as a group, like what version, or not version, because they're different languages, but if I want to go learn K, what do I go learn? K4, K6, K7? And you'll get a different answer. And there's different documentations for each one. And it would be like the equivalent of like, imagine all the different LISPs were created by one person, you know, this godlike, you know, entity. And every time, you know, the individual went from, you know, LISP to Common LISP to Scheme
转向 Guile，转向 Racket，再转向 Clojure。而每一次，他都只是按下了删除键。没有——你知道的，解释理由或任何东西。你只能跟着它，并且——把这段历史记在脑子里。幸运的是，我们在 Arraycast 上采访了约翰·欧内斯特（John Ernest），他大致口述了所有不同的 K 语言的历史，以及 K 语言之间的主要区别。但是，是的，这是一个——这是一个烂摊子。我希望他——我希望他能改变主意，你知道，他上播客或在一个地方做演讲，讲述这段历史，你知道，他为什么从 K2 到 K3 做出改变数据模型或类似事情的决定？因为我认为他的作品中有很多天才之处。而它——它甚至不是迷失在时间的风尘中。它正在迷失，是因为他——他按下了删除键。是的，他正在积极地——现在，你觉得他——你觉得他有备份吗？还是你觉得他真的——我百分之百相信他实际上是从他的电脑里擦除了它们，就像大多数——我想约翰·欧内斯特在我们采访他时说过，他实际上在本地保存了许多不同的
to Guile to Racket to Closure. And every single time, he just hit the delete button. Didn't, you know, explain reasoning or anything. And you would just have to follow it and like, keep this history in your head. Like, luckily we got to talk to John Ernest on Arraycast and he sort of gave a oral history of all the different Ks and what are the major differences in the, in the K languages. But yeah, it's, it is, it's a, it's a mass. I hope he, I hope he has a change of heart, you know, and he goes on a podcast or gives
K 语言，是在阿瑟开发它们的时候保存的，但他甚至不能发布它们，因为它们受版权保护。所以像互联网上存在的 K 版本，都是人们逆向工程出来的版本。比如有两个不同的 K6，一个是约翰做的，另一个是另一个人做的，一个是用 JavaScript 写的，另一个是用别的语言写的，我想可能是 C。还有其他几个不同的 K 变体，但它们基本上都是——有人拥有 K 的可执行文件，无论他们是从阿瑟还是其他人那里得到的，或者他们只是拥有文档，
a talk at some and gives the history and, you know, why did he make the decision from K2 to K3 to to change the data model or something like that? Because I think there's a lot of genius in his work. And it's it's it's not even getting lost to the annals of time. It's getting lost because he's he's hitting the delete key. Yeah, he is actively. Now, do you think he's you think he's got a backup or you think he actually i believe him 100 that he actually like wipes it from his computer and like most i think john ernest when we talked to him he said that he actually locally has a bunch of the different
然后他们逆向工程了它的行为，这就像是——这太疯狂了。难道这不疯狂吗？想到这一点太疯狂了——太疯狂了。K4、K6 或其他什么，甚至 K3 的方言或版本存在——
k languages as arthur was working on them but he can't even release them because they're under copyright. And so like the versions of K that exist on the internet are versions that people have reverse engineered. Like there's two different K6s, one's by John and one's by another individual, one's like written in JavaScript and the other one in another language, I think maybe C. And there's a couple other different K variants, but like they're all basically people that had a executable of K, whether they got it from Arthur or someone else, or they just had the documentation
我知道有几家公司拥有 K3 的许可证，那就是历史。你知道，人们可能会说，哦，Lisp 比不同的 K 语言要大得多。但是，你知道，我不知道。我认为这里有一些类比，就像——想象一下，你知道有人在不同的 Lisp 上按下删除键。无论如何，那是一个题外话。我有问题要问你们两个——我的意思是，C++ 是一门多范式语言，因为它支持过程式、面向对象、函数式的编程风格。我们有像 Prolog 这样的语言，它是基于逻辑的风格。
and they reverse engineered the behavior, which is like, that's crazy. Like, isn't that crazy? That's crazy to think that like- That's crazy. The dialects or the versions that exist of, you know, K4, K6 or whatever, or K3 even,
我们有，我想——嗯，你有什么？APL、BQN，数组语言。是的，好吧，数组。Smalltalk 是面向对象的。我们现在有了这些量子语言。那么，我们已经找到了所有可能的编程范式了吗？没有，因为我认为下一个可能在今天被发明的编程范式，
which I know that there's a couple companies that have licenses to K3, that, like, that's the history. Like, you know, people might say, oh, Lisp is way bigger than just the different K languages. But, like, I don't know. I think there is some analogy there that, like, imagine, you you know someone was hitting the delete key on on different different uh lisps anyways that was that was a tangent there uh i have a question for the two of you i mean c++ is multi-paradigmatic language in that it supports procedural, object-oriented, functional coding styles. We have languages like Prolog, which is a logic-based style.
是人工智能辅助编程范式。我们在一个编程真正变成了向某个 AI 提供提示词（prompt），由它去为你完成任务或为你编写代码的世界里该如何编程？我认为，这显然是提示词工程（prompt engineering）的领域，它正在引领的方向将带来新的编程范式。是的，我同意。这听起来很疯狂，但真的有人——当我们正在视频中进行研究讨论时，发表了那个评论。想象一下，你栈中的新一层就像是你正在向你的 Git 仓库提交
We've got, I guess, well, you've got what? EPL, BQN, array languages. Yeah, okay, array. Smalltalk is object-oriented. And we now have these quantum languages. So have we found all the programming paradigms that are possible? No, because I think the next programming paradigm
你的提示词，然后即时的反应是——“你知道，那不是确定性的，等等等等”，但是——想想编译器栈的所有不同层，从各种中间表示（IR）一直到汇编，这就像——有多少——我的意思是，外面绝对有汇编生成专家，但就像——就我个人而言，我到底有多了解一个 C++ 编译器在一天结束时在做什么？就像布莱斯了解得更多的那些东西，关于指令级并行性以及它们重新组织程序去做某事的方式。我的意思是，有一半时间，我认为大多数时间它是确定性的。但有时你会发现，你知道，它重新排列了你期望它完成的方式，但这是为了利益，因为你知道——你输入了一些东西，但它知道，哦，当你做一些——你知道的，测试一个数字是否
that's likely being invented today is the AI-assisted programming paradigm. How do we program in a world where programming is really giving a prompt to some AI that goes and does the task for you or writes the code for you. And that's, I think, clearly the field of prompt engineering and what it's leading to is going to lead to new programming paradigms. Yeah, I agree. It sounds crazy, but literally someone, when we were having a research discussion in video, made that comment. Imagine your new layer on your stack is like you are committing to your git repository
是偶数时，大多数人不会使用按位与（bitwise and one）或者什么的，但你可以让编译器识别出那些东西。无论如何，这——我认为这并不是一个遥不可及的牵强附会，对于大语言模型或 AI 现今存在并似乎已被刻在石头上的任何限制——带着巨大的保留态度来看待它，因为它是一个新兴领域，而且是一个不断发展的领域，这是一个不断发展的领域，就像——是的，大语言模型带来的缺乏确定性是进行生产规模开发的问题吗？是的，但这是一个我认为不会永远存在的限制。你知道，如果你看看今天的大语言模型——它们不是很实用，
your prompts and then the immediate reaction is like well you know that's not deterministic blah blah blah but like think about all the different layers of the compiler stack from like the different irs all the way down to assembly and it's like how much i mean there are definitely assembly generation experts out there but like like me personally, how much do I actually understand about what a C++ compiler is doing at the end of the day? Like stuff Bryce knows a lot more about like instruction level parallelism and the way that they're like reorienting your program to do something. And I mean half the time, I think most of the time it's deterministic. But there are times where like you end up, you know, it's rearranging the way that you would expect it to be done but it's it's for the benefit because you know you use you type something but it knows oh when you're doing some you know testing whether a number is
从成本角度、延迟角度、带宽角度来看，它们不是最实用或最高效的工具。但随着领域逐渐成熟并变得更加商品化，它会变得更加实用，我们将克服许多这些问题。布莱斯，当你在说那个的时候，我在想——比如你在《华尔街》里看到的最初的手机。那是什么？有一部电影叫《华尔街》，由
even most people don't use the bitwise you know and one or whatever uh but you can you can get the compiler to recognize that stuff anyway so it's it's i don't think it's that far of a fetch to any any limit like any limitation on the that uh it exists and seems to be written in stone today for large language models or ai um take with a huge grain of salt because it's it's a nascent field and it's an evolving it's an evolving field like yeah is the is the lack of determinism that you get out of large language model the problem for doing things production scale yes but that's a restriction that i don't think will always be around you know if you look at large language models today like they're not they're not very practical um like cost wise uh latency wise bandwidth wise they're not they're not the most practical or most efficient tool but practical, like cost-wise, latency-wise, bandwidth-wise.
迈克尔·什么主演的，无论如何，他们拿着这些巨大的东西，就像你知道的——只有拥有大量资金的人才买得起这些——所谓的“手机”。但如果你看到那个然后说：“哦，这将是未来，每个人都会有一部，它将彻底改变我们的生活方式，”你可能会觉得：“嗯，大概不会吧。”但那——那并不是手机最终演变成的样子，对吧？并且经历了几次不同的迭代。它们有翻盖手机，然后智能手机——你知道，iPhone 是一个完全的、你知道的，游戏规则改变者。
They're not the most practical or most efficient tool, but as the field matures and it becomes more commoditized, it'll become more practical and we'll overcome a lot of those problems. While you were saying that, Bryce, I was thinking of like the original cell phone that you see in like the Wall Street. What is it? There's a movie called wall street uh with
它们不是最实用或最高效的工具，但随着该领域的成熟和商品化，它会变得更实用，我们将克服许多这些问题。布莱斯，当你在说的时候，我想到了你在《华尔街》里看到的那种最初的手机。那是什么？有一部电影叫《华尔街》，里面有
michael something and anyways they've got these like huge things and it's like you know only the people that had you know oodles of money could afford these these quote-unquote cell phones but it's like if you saw that and said oh that's going to be the future everyone's going to have one it's going to completely change the way we go about our lives you'd probably be like yeah probably not but like that wasn't that wasn't what cell phones went on to be, right? And there was a few different iterations. They had the flip phones and then the smartphones were, you know, the iPhone was a complete, you know, game changer.
迈克尔什么的人，无论如何，他们拿着这些巨大的东西，你知道，只有拥有巨额财富的人才买得起这些所谓的手机，但如果你看到那个并说“哦，这将是未来，每个人都会有一部，它将彻底改变我们的生活方式”，你可能会觉得“嗯，可能不会”，但事实并非如此，手机后来没有变成那样，对吧？而且经历了几个不同的迭代。它们有翻盖手机，然后智能手机，你知道的，iPhone完全是一个改变游戏规则的东西。
And, you know, I expect that that's what the next 20 years is going to be like. You know, there's going to be a couple of these big innovations. Is that not just a different way of, okay, I suppose it is a different way of writing program. Whereas I'm thinking of the programming paradigms as being, oh, I suppose, yes, actually, paradigms are really a way of thinking, isn't it? It's so, if you're writing a prompt, that's thinking. Okay, fair enough. I mean, quantum, you know, the paradigms for quantum programming are also very nascent, I would say that's a new thing. And there may be other things like quantum in the future, you know, the paradigms of quantum for me are also very nascent. I would say that's a new thing. And there may be other things like quantum in the future, you know. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to the GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts and questions. Thanks for listening.
而且，你知道，我预计未来的二十年大概就是这个样子。你知道，会出现几个这样的大型创新。这不就是一种不同的方式吗？好吧，我想这确实是一种编写程序的不同方式。而我在思考编程范式时，哦，我想是的，实际上，范式确实是一种思维方式，对吧？所以，如果你在写提示词，那就是在思考。好吧，有道理。我的意思是，量子，你知道，量子编程的范式也才刚刚萌芽，我认为那是一个新事物。未来可能还会有像量子这样的其他东西，你知道，对我来说量子的范式也才刚开始萌芽。我认为那是一个新事物。未来可能还会有像量子这样的其他东西，你知道。请务必查看您播客应用中或访问 ADSP the podcast dot com 的节目文稿，获取今天节目中我们提到的任何内容的链接，以及可以留下评论、想法和问题的 GitHub 讨论区链接。感谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。